[Music]
school superintendent Dr Jara is
committed to improving student
achievement and also investing in his
staff and it comes as the governor says
he wants to invest another two billion
dollars toward education Joshua peguero
is digging into the most important
issues affecting your family in Dr
jara's state of the school's address
last school year as you can see on this
graphic the high school graduation rate
at CCSD was 81 percent but
superintendent Dr Jesus Jara says he's
committed to increasing this by eight
percentage points we identified 60
schools
differentiated student support
intense monitoring intense coaching
intense support
out of those 60 schools last year 50 of
them made gain Dr Jara laid out his
vision on improving student achievement
one way is increasing the pupil to
teacher ratio Nevada currently ranks
49th in the country in that category it
doesn't help CCSD that it has a
significant teacher shortage most of the
openings are in areas of the valley
where predominantly Black and Hispanic
students live teachers have choice right
so then we have to work within our
bargaining units to then provide more
incentives you know the work may be
different and how do we incentivize
Educators to want to go into that so
we're having those conversations right
now I mean you'll learn that John
varadida executive director of the Clark
County Education Association says he
supports efforts to increase the
graduation rate but it has to be more
than that we're not interested in just
spiking the graduation numbers without
kids really graduating with a good
foundation of Education Governor Joe
Lombardo pledges to invest two billion
dollars into the state's education
budget valadita says with this money
comes accountability and results I think
the superintendent has one year to start
producing significant outcomes I mean
one year after that budget has been
adopted in July I asked Dr Jara about
this data you see here is the chronic
low attendance rate in schools last year
it was 41 percent compared to three
years ago when it was 22 percent Dr
Jarvis says this data should serve as a
call to action for our community Joshua
progero eight news now